because I'm because we've never had
anyone on this podcast that went through
this oh cool yeah ask away yeah so this
is very are you scared when you first
realize you were pregnant no because I
wanted I wanted to be okay yeah I'm 34
so I'm like I wanted it to happen old
are you I'm 33
right we over here you're the example
gee thank you we have a year yeah yeah
science like science now's nuts I color
in in vitro because they have they
collect a couple of like viable embryos
and then they look to see which ones are
probably gonna take the best yeah then
you get to choose between a boy and a
girl so like for instance Christy Teegan
and John Legend yeah the first they
chose a girl and in this second one they
chose a boy oh my god can you give it
abilities like superpower like I want I
want autism but the rain mankind like
talented like a talented where you can
count things will quit you know man
composes yeah we already halfway there
you're Asian man like aren't Asians just
naturally born doing math I can't count
cards in Vegas yeah yeah that's Rain Man
skill you know there's even something
that people that's people are doing now
we're women who aren't able to have
their to carry their own usually get a
surrogate right but now they're doing
uterus implants and they've done this in
Sweden I think eight times successfully
will where they will the the mom will
take an immunosuppressive drug and it's
kind of like a kidney or a liver
transplant and the mom will take on
someone else's uterus because she wants
to conceive and carry her own child to
term oh cool it's not her uterus it's
from somebody like a donor who cares
like you lose it anyway yeah that's
crazy right that's really cool
it's crazy so you can choose eyes you
can choose gender yep yeah you can
choose how about physical things
superhero babies now you know like you
know can you tease about it son to have
a better deck I think our son will have
an okay dick has my dad a huge dick how
do you know your dad had a huge thing
well
towards this is sad but towards the end
of his life I said to care for old old
dude he was like a shower definitely a
shower because science my skin drags off
the body did you guys know this and it
goes uncircumcised make circumcised
oh then your argument goes out the
window dude okay and I rest my case
I rest my case no time to learn and all
my uncle's had big dicks - how'd you
know that I think not seen your own
dad's big guys I never seen my uncle's
day ever oh no before before we get to
that can we just take a moment answers
where we can Wow I love me undies that
they're great but my point is is this
you [ __ ] your uncle's no did you suck
your uncle's dick I never you guys like
going to spawn okay so like one time in
the Philippines we went to the province
cuz my family owns land in the mountains
and there was a supply there like a lake
and that's where everyone showers in the
province and so all my cousins I know
all of their dicks I know what they look
like and I know that my family lineup of
dicks no faces you're like uncle brother
right would you do that and also my best
friend had sex with my cousin and she
said he he had one of the biggest dicks
ever
Wow let me ask you this yeah there was a
photo of my page Gilbert's dick brothers
dead I could I know I know your
brother's dick - oh I don't know so many
dicks really have a photo I just thick
is it thick wide is it what no it's
actually like a very normal dick oh it's
a button-up buff at all that huh oh it's
veiny
yeah we're all vain you know we should
do this you and Gilbert should go to the
bathroom take a picture of your penises
and I will tell you which one
and I will be like who's its title I
wouldn't know that I don't know what
mine is because I'm no well you don't I
have a extra turtleneck on mine oh yeah
he's uncircumcised yeah
oh you're circumcised yeah yeah that's
pretty obvious oh yeah just something
this stuff gets caught in there no
because I'll have to clean it because I
didn't know about that until I was like
a freshman in high school so I probably
got a physical or at school or something
the doctors like a pull back to check
I'm like oh I can't do that he said hurt
what he's like you're supposed to be
I've been doing this since like middle
school so I finally did it
it's called thick thick thick thick
thick is the word in Filipino of
shmegmer that's cute oh I'm sorry guys
burn all that it was crusty like it fell
off in all it was it was moist it was
like cheese cream cream you go to
Yogurtland or Pinkberry she's classes
like that cheesecake bites oh my god our
girl had discharging it dry crunchy it
was like what do you got brittle are
like a toffee brittle brittle and you
kept going oh yeah yeah yeah just like
that yeah yeah anyway uh yeah so switch
gears
[Music]